it is a pivotal day for politics five
states across the country hold primaries
today arizona michigan missouri kansas
and washington for many republican
candidates today is a test of loyalty to
former president trump earning his
endorsement can of course mean a big
boost in the primary so in missouri eric
greitens and eric schmidt are two of the
leading gop candidates running for a
senate seat well yesterday the former
president made an endorsement in that
race he wrote proud to announce that
eric
all caps has my complete and total
endorsement but here's the thing
he didn't actually say
which eric he was talking about
both candidates then tweeted a thank you
another state heading to the polls is
arizona where today's election could be
a test for how far former president
trump's endorsement can go in a swing
state that's where we find our ed
o'keefe ed good morning
vlad good to see you good morning from
arizona where election denying donald
trump endorsed candidates are in the
lead in today's gop primaries if they
win today
they have a good chance of winning in
november and taking control of a major
2024 presidential battleground state
in arizona's race for governor and for
u.s senate candidates who were backed by
former president donald trump and deny
reality about 2020 are in the lead
and that's increasingly what republican
primary voters want i wouldn't vote for
anybody that he hasn't
endorsed that's how i feel nationwide 57
percent of republicans in the new cbs
news battleground tracker poll say
they're more likely to vote for a
candidate who gets an endorsement from
the former president in arizona's gop
primary for governor that's what's
helping carrie lake a former tv news
anchor she's a one-time barack obama
supporter who's become a leading
election skeptic still she thinks she
can win in november and i think our
policies appeal to independents
democrats and republicans but in a
general election our new poll finds a
trump endorsement makes registered
voters overall
less likely to vote for a candidate and
that's what worries lake's primary
opponent karen taylor-robson she also
won't say if president biden won in
2020. the one thing i know for certain
is the wrong guy is in the white house
and that's my answer and i'm sticking to
it but robson's backed by the sitting
governor and former vice president mike
pence and says lake's too extreme to win
i don't believe kerry lake can get
elected
in november she has she has fashioned
herself as such an extremist the likely
democratic opponent katie hobbs agrees
can you beat carrie lake in november she
is unappealing to the majority of voters
especially the voters with no party
affiliation which most of them identify
that way because they don't like either
extreme trump's influence even stretches
down the ballot to a race featuring
rusty bowers who testified earlier this
summer about the former president's
attempts to overturn the 2020 results
you're asking me to do something against
my oath and i will not break my oath
trump endorsed his opponent bowers is
also concerned his party is getting too
extreme for voters there's an idea that
if we sanitize the party somehow it'll
attract people but really the party gets
smaller and pretty soon a phone booth
will handle it
it's telling that the former president
is reaching all the way down to a state
senate race it just shows you how much
influence he's trying to have over the
gop across the country also today here
in arizona keep an eye on the secretary
of state primary here like in many other
places secretaries of state oversee
elections there are trump-inspired
election deniers on the ballot there too
and democrats and republicans concerned
that if one of those candidates wins in
november they could at least slow down
the tabulation of results in the 2024
presidential election a reminder there
are a lot of local and statewide races
across the country this year eureka with
far-reaching national implications yeah
absolutely ed thank you